des balises des boîtiers des cartes et
des milliards de combinaisons pour faire
marcher ses neurones et courir les
enfants
[Applaudissements]
peut-être qu'il faut cliquer alors que
si tu restes à trouver les cochons pièce
pas qu'on me propose tiens bizarre d'un
stress de lézat rougerie tous ses amis
sont invités à prendre sans même s'en
rendre compte c'est le principe de leur
eau
une méthode qui allie neuro sciences et
technologies pour faire tous passés
maths français que sais-je encore sur
l'air du jeu ou comme dirait la fontaine
bien leur sert de courir il vont
s'instruira points le pari c'est
justement de faire travailler la tête et
les jambes de proposer un contenu qui
permet de faire réfléchir et le cerveau
et de le faire le plus vite possible
là vous pouvez remarquer que les enfants
bat tout seul se motiver pour tous selon
leur a pas dit courir parce que
finalement le rythme d'un naturel d'un
enfant cette fois c'est de courir sauter
crier oh c'est ce qui se passe c'est
plus comme l'école puisse comme la récré
les deux en même temps
applicable dès 3 ans sans limite d'âge
la méthode fait de l'enfant l'acteur de
son apprentissage sans pour autant
mettre l'enseignant de côté on essaye de
replacer l'enseignant dans sa véritable
fonction qui est juste d'organiser un
milieu suffisamment riche pour kylie
apprentissage on met trop de pression
aux enseignants pour dire il faut que
les gamins apprennent telle ou telle
chose
sans faire confiance à l'élève là
l'enseignant est là juste pour organiser
et répondre aux sollicitations des
élèves et à propos de sollicitations
voici celle de mélinda gdiem un maintien
parfait certes mais l'éducation
nationale pour moins vite que toi la
méthode commence tout juste à s aimer
l'école de fontain serait paraît-il sur
les rangs